john crick of the toronto sun spoke to
dean blandino who used to be the nfl's
vp of officiating now is a rules
consultant with fox blandino said the
competition committee has come around i
guess blandino is reporting that he's
spoken to people who have said the
competition committee has come around on
the idea of the sky judge chris the sky
judge could be finding support for the
me but now look just because the
competition committee's on board doesn't
mean the owners are going to be on board
they may not want to spend the big
mammoo on having an extra official at
every game and i don't know what the
shape or the form of this guy judge will
be but you know this is what we want i
want someone there to bridge the gap
off the field someone who's in a booth
watching all the camera angles we see at
home who is able to communicate directly
with the officials on the field who are
trying to primarily not get trampled by
the gladiators tell them what they've
missed in real time let them know right
away pick up a flag drop a flag move the
ball yes there was a fumble no there
wasn't a fumble we made a mistake let's
fix it the perspective of someone who
sees what we're seeing and can assist in
the officiating process that's what they
need and hopefully they're moving the
direction to do that no you're right i
think there's great value in that and
mike i give you all the credit i mean
this was this was you from the get-go
you've been down you know banging on the
table for this and you know really
honestly i don't think it's come up or
if it's you know supposedly true what
dean blandino is saying i don't think
that comes up unless you uh haven't been
saying it you've been very consistent
with it i'm with you at first i
questioned it but i think it makes a lot
of sense especially this day and age
where we're at right now with
gambolizing uh legal legalized gamble
gambling and everything like that i
almost said it again legal hover simpson
thomas simpson making a guess
on pft live today
we're gonna do some gamblizing after the
show chris uh yes gamblizing but that's
that's um you know one of the things
though to me too that you know it's
great here not that the sky judge will
get every call right but again to what
you said mike it's gonna make consumers
people watching the game just a little
bit more comfortable if you're betting
money on a weekly basis to go all right
well here's another you know another
factor or another you know box that has
to be checked to make sure calls are the
right way and there's a little more
oversight here so i'm all in favor of it
and let me tell you it's becoming an
annual thing and i know rich mckay
drafted you when you were in tampa so
you've got a soft spot for him but
you know the the process starts every
year with rich mckay
saying
and then by the time the time comes to
actually do it he's just it's a 180. um
i i don't know what it is but last year
it was the whole thing out we're not
going to do anything about replay review
for pass interference we're not going to
fix that we're fine with that it only
happens once every 100 years we're fine
with it and then they put in replay
review for passenger affairs this year
and a sky judge that's not going to
happen and now they're moving in the
direction of at least recommending it
but again at least 24 owners have to
agree to that it's going to be a topic
they take up in may they still haven't
scrapped their plans to meet in la in
may uh i don't think they're going to be
meeting in l.a in may i think there's
going to be another conference call at
which this topic gets discussed and
we'll see if there's enough support
among the owners to push it through
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports